continuamos con la historia del fondo
mutualista de pipe entonces el año pasa
y aún después de pagarle a [ __ ] el 1 por
ciento y teníamos 500 dólares de bienes
bajo gestión todos estos bienes bajo
gestión
un año después van a van a digamos que
van a como mencioné en el final del
último vídeo a uno a mil dólares así que
[ __ ] es realmente bueno o realmente
suerte o un poquito de ambos tal vez así
que ahora está en mil dólares
déjenme dibujarlo así aquí está en mil
dólares y aún tienen los mismos cinco
inversionistas aquí y leo el suertudo de
ser uno de ellos verdad así que aquí
están los cinco inversionistas déjenme
dibujar las acciones una dos tres cuatro
cinco acciones muy bien ahora cada una
de estas acciones bueno a los mil
dólares se les llama el valor unitario
de la cuota parte ok el book vamos a
llamarlo book sólo para darle un poco de
terminología al asunto así que hay un
book por cada acción el book por acción
aquí es de 200 dólares aunque sólo
tomamos el total del book y lo dividimos
por las acciones y lo que es especial de
los puntos fondos mutuos de inversión
abierta es que el cierre o al final del
día tanto podemos remover acciones del
fondo ok o pueden crearse otras así en
el primer vídeo les mostré cómo leo
quería comprar una acción ok y entonces
se incrementó el número de acciones y
tuvo que crear una acción para que la
comprará no le vendió una acción que ya
existiera así que puedes imaginarte que
después de este tipo de
el desempeño más gente compraría
acciones así que ahora ellos tendrían
que comprar digamos para hacer las cosas
justas en 200 dólares por acción verdad
así que digamos que cinco más personas
quieren comprar a 200 dólares por acción
así que lo que haría o más bien el fondo
mutuo realmente no speed verdad sino la
corporación crearía cinco nuevas
acciones una dos tres cuatro y cinco si
sólo había una persona ese día pues
crearía una acción si había diez
personas ese día pues crearía diez
acciones muy bien y puedes seguir
haciendo esto y el book de cada una de
estas 200 dólares así que la de estas
acciones a cada persona y tienen que
contribuir con 200 dólares ok
con esto pone otros mil dólares en la
mesa que ahora [ __ ] puede manejar muy
bien y así el book total para el fondo
es de dos mil dólares en esto en este
caso y tendrá un 1% de cuota por
administración de estos 22 mil dólares
verdad ahora digamos que adelantamos un
poquito el tiempo que vamos a darle un
poquito más adelante
digamos que pite empiezan no tener
buen año así que digamos que adelantamos
a un año tal que pitt tiene un
rendimiento negativo del 10% así que si
empezaste en 2000 dólares y eso es
cuando ya has quitado su cuota de
administración lo empezaste en 2000
dólares
pierdes 10% en un año así que baja a mil
800 dólares déjenme poner esto en un
nuevo color así que ahora está en 1800
dólares no está dibujado completamente
escala pero espero que tengan muy bien
la idea de lo que quiero decir ahora
estamos en 1800 10 mil 800 dólares pero
aún tenemos un total de 10 acciones aún
tenemos un total de 10 acciones déjenme
hacer mi mejor intento para dibujar las
10 acciones una dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho nueve y diez
éstas deberían ser del mismo tamaño pero
bueno ahora el book por acción será de
1800 dividido entre 10 que son 180
dólares y digamos que leo se asusta
verdad se asustó por este reciente
desempeño y que tiene otros compromisos
de dinero así que dice vaya [ __ ] tú
necesitas comprar mi acción de regreso
así que lo que pitt hace es que le
devuelve los 180 dólares y el total del
book perdería 180 dólares verdad baja
quitamos esta acción de aquí y que sería
1800 menos 180 que es 1620 verdad el
book y ellos comprarían de regreso a la
acción de leo así que la cancelan
cancelan una de las acciones pero
fíjense el book por acción no cambia al
reembolsarme la acción no cambia lo que
le ocurre a todos los demás ahora tienes
1620 dividido por nueve acciones y esto
debería darte a un 180 dólares por
acción
verdad si dice mis matemáticas bien así
1800 menos 180 te dan 1620 y esto nos
debería dar 180 por acción pero esta es
la naturaleza de un fondo mutuo de
inversión abierta puedes seguir y seguir
creando
acciones o quitando las cuando alguien
quiere su dinero de vuelta esencialmente
compras de regreso a la acción de ellos
dándoles su dinero cuando las compras de
vuelta y remueves la acción así que en
un fondo de inversión abierta puede
permanecer creciendo o encogiéndose
puede seguir agregando o quitando
acciones según sus inversionistas lo
difícil de todo esto desde el punto de
vista del administrador es que ellos
tienen que administrar esto tienen que
administrar esta constante compra y
venta con el público tienen que
administrar todo todo y si lo piensas no
pueden tener todo su dinero invertido en
activos ilíquidos o en reservas
regulares ellos tienen que mantener
cierta cantidad que usualmente desde el
3 al 5 por ciento que es una parte
digamos de estos dos mil dólares que es
en efectivo y desde el punto de vista de
un inversionista ellos dirían bueno si
soy bueno invirtiendo debería tratar de
minimizar la cantidad de efectivo que
tengo porque no va a tener un
rendimiento en efectivo porque es
inversión abierta porque los
inversionistas pueden venir y decir ahí
quiero mi dinero debes tener una pequeña
cantidad de efectivo a la mano como
parte de reserva para poder comprar de
vuelta a las acciones